good morning everyone I hope you're all
well thank you for joining me I hope you
and all of your families are healthy of
course and thank you for joining me so
bit of housekeeping before I start
chatting away and answering your
questions and going through the slide
deck that I put together today in the in
the you should be able to see a chat
function and public chat so use that to
answer my questions and just to kick
that off I'd love to know where people
are joining from today where you're
based where you're working out of and
how many Easter eggs you air over the
weekend and then you're gonna have at
the top as well Q&A ask your questions
here so I've just sent a question and
you'll be able to see that and you can
also click up vote whenever you want to
for the questions that you do like and
make sure you click up vote and I'll
make sure I get those and answered so as
I'm going through this make sure you
wash your questions and and then what
I'm gonna do and very quickly now is
just and do a very quick poll which will
just help me focus on certain areas and
during this session to ensure that all
of you get the most out of it so the
first one I'm just going to share with
you all now is do you come to the first
personal branding webinar if yes click
yes and if no click no because that
would just help me in terms of how much
to go into sort of my background or how
much to sort of brush over that or
whatever and that just be useful for me
to know and Felicity Colchester no eggs
Alexandra was working to the window now
working near the wall happy days kitchen
and leaves no chocolate for me yeah I
think the thing is I mean what went on
in our house
my girlfriend really wanting some
chocolate eggs but not sure how
essential that is I feel like that would
be very frowned upon if you went to the
supermarket and just filled your basket
or trolley with Easter eggs not sure how
well that would have gone down cool
right so let's look at the open know
okay cool so quite a few people didn't
come to the the first one that's fine
okay right so let's crack on with this
then and actually the other poll I'll do
is which should also help me is I want
to start that one as well so what is
your biggest challenge when it comes to
personal branding I know some of you
sent over a lot of questions and just
when you get to seconds click what
option you think is most relevant to you
and that also helped me sort of dive
into a particular topic in a bit more
detail basically so I'm going to do that
so right let's do this as you guys are
doing that I'm gonna do the very the
very quick story because some of you
have been here before and I want to
really focus on some of the things I
didn't expand on in the in the first
webinar so my objective today is really
simple I want to give you some real
practical tips on how you should be
delivering content on LinkedIn that's
given a give you the best possible
chance of driving engagement with your
target audience and I'm gonna go into a
lot more detail on what content is
working right now from what I'm seeing
and and what I'm doing with my clients
at the moment that's working and I'm
gonna answer your questions
definitely have plenty of time to do Q&A
but the two things aren't going to
really focus on today is how I my best
advice to approach delivering content on
LinkedIn and then also giving you really
practical ideas that you can action to
my so very quickly just to set the scene
and sort of how I got to this point is
very quickly so my story the short story
is working with Clinton for two and a
half years and my biggest challenge in
my first show was getting hold of enough
clients and candidates that I could help
on the phone I learned
all the traditional methods Smasher
switchboards job boards database the law
I made zero pounds out of LinkedIn my
first year how I got taught to use it
was he should when you get a job make
sure you post about it and this made me
zero pounds shocked right so that's how
I was using LinkedIn and I made the
decision gone into year to that what
else can I do to give me the best
possible chance to have more success in
recruitment and I was going to carry on
doing what my boss told me which was
putting in the work volume of activity
smash of phones but what else can I be
doing my market was insurance market and
I knew my clients and candidates hung
out there so I made the decision that I
was going to try and use LinkedIn
differently compared to how I was using
it in my first year and how my
competitors were using it so how I
started to use it was I started to
document my journey as working as a
being an insurance recruit in the market
so all of these things I didn't year one
but I didn't shout about it remained
offline it remained in the 101 sort of
meetings learning seminars and
networking events but that's that's how
I started my content journey and this is
how I started to build my brand in the
insurance market and it had a big impact
on my recruitment desk and just helped
me from anywhere business development
sessions kind of engagement sessions it
just it just really impacted my
recruitment desk so I started to build
confidence start to share videos after I
got more comfortable with sharing
content on LinkedIn it gave me the
confidence to start the recruitment
rollercoaster podcast that some of you
may know that a host or listened to and
that's had a huge impact on my career
and it put me in touch with my old boss
Sean who is the founder of hooks on
media and that's when I joined them work
for them over a year and they're an
inbound marketing exclusive works the
recruitment industry and then it's led
me to where I am today start my own
business and my mission is really simple
it's to help build personal brands for
passionate recruiters so they can reach
more people that can help impact more
lives and in turn make more money that's
my very quick story as to how building
my brand has had a real impact on my
career and what I've been talking a lot
about to my clients recently and also in
the first webinar is this should be your
mindset towards your branding efforts
right now it's about becoming the
lighthouse of your market and so if your
clients and candidates can come to you
to understand what challenges people are
going through how people are adapting
what solutions are people coming up to
be the source of positive news in your
market your branding efforts should be
approached with the mindset of I will
need to be the lighthouse of my market
that's the analysis that I've been using
that's been resonating with people and
that is sort of the the advice that I've
been giving my clients when they're
worried about just talking about the
[ __ ] coronavirus basically so that's
that's sort of why I'm gonna expand on
today and just to set the scene and
finish this off very quick intro over is
this is the really simple definition of
personal branding it is not rocket
science you will all understand it's
personal branding is the practice of
marketing people and their careers as
brands it's all about you it's what your
clients and candidates say about you
when you're not in the room it's how
you're perceived in the market and yes
recruiters have a personal brand already
a lot of people when I ask this in sort
of my one-on-one sessions or in group
sessions and say have you guys already
got a personal brand then a lot of
people will say no because a
straightaway think of the short front
window they shouldn't think of their
online presence but all of you already
have a personal brand that's why you get
referrals it's why you get
recommendations it's it's you delivering
for your clients and candidates it's
it's basically remained offline this is
this is the big thing that's changing
now a lot of you guys that have been in
the market way longer than I have your
reputation has stayed within your
one-on-one phone calls your networking
events it's remained offline and what's
become more and more important now is
that everything that you build and work
your socks off to build offline
intelligent reputation you need to make
sure that's also communicated online
with your personal brand right and what
that doesn't mean is that you can reach
thousands of people now if you haven't
done this this was one of the exercises
I said to do in the first webinar and
that was to really encourage you to take
action look at what your competitors are
doing this is what I did when I was in
recruitment and it was the best
motivator and I still use it now of
every single coin that I work with
if you have not looked at your
competitors and I'm talking about actual
individuals in your market that wake up
every single morning to take money out
of your pocket have a look at what
they're doing and how they're using
LinkedIn there's a very good chance that
they're doing [ __ ] all and that's why I
want you to look at it so right now
which is even more important are your
competitors hiding under a rock if they
are hiding under a rock and they're not
doing anything to deliver value share
solutions be the lighthouse then this
should really motivate you to take
action so make sure that you look at
your competitors what are they doing
this they're not doing anything remember
that when you're worried about taking
action or you're not taking action make
sure you do that so this sort of proven
process that I've been taking recruiters
for over the last 10 11 months is this
free piece for believing a personal
brand P for purpose P for plan people
paying forward if you combine all of
these things and this is what I've used
to build my own brand and what I've been
helping recruiters with this is part of
what I'm gonna go over today but what
I'm gonna really expand on is I'm gonna
focus on how you can deliver content on
LinkedIn that is going to give you the
best possible chance to drive engagement
with your target audience what I really
dived into previously was thinking of
ideas how to think of ideas and content
ideas which is the first challenge right
but the second biggest challenge that I
get oh sorry actually what I'm gonna
assume actually going into this is that
you've got some content ideas now if you
haven't got content ideas think about
these questions what are the biggest
headaches and challenges that your
clients are facing right now yes
coronavirus but how is it impact in
their professional world and personal
world how is it impact in their culture
are they struggling to cultivate or have
the culture they have in the office
remotely are they struggling to build
bring people and remotely do they know
how to use him I don't know think about
the biggest headaches and challenges
your clients have right now and that
should formulate what you should be
talking about and creating content about
likewise of candidates biggest headache
sunshine is your candidates are facing
right now and trust me this will be
ongoing always have this mindset when
you're on the phones people
what what and what what I used to do is
every time I heard something three times
I'd write that down bullet point that's
a third time that someone said to me
Hisham I'm worried about other people's
opinions right that could be a Content
idea right so this is how you're gonna
continue to cultivate the content ideas
that you can talk about and I'm going to
assume that you have some of these today
as I'm going to go into how you can
deliver content around the content ideas
so the second biggest challenge I get
from recruiters after I have no idea
what to talk about Hisham is this what
if I get buried online totally
understand that it's not nice and I've
been there I've definitely got an abuse
online people just weird and it's also
what it also goes into is I don't want
to come across on professional to my
network and let's look at this poll
actually very quickly which some of you
showed me so thank you for filling that
out yeah so the biggest challenge shock
knowing what's quite content about right
totally understand that but the second
one is not wanting to come across the
wrong way to my network I'm worried
about other people's opinion so that's
what I'm gonna focus on today so and
with that and so part of that challenge
as well as who am I to talk about
technical topics I'm a recruiter this is
why I also get a lot is the Hisham I'm
work that I'm just going to use a tech
space just because it's easy he shoulda
mama Tech recruiter and I don't know how
to write codes and I don't want to talk
about technical topics just in case a
developer looks at it and they rip me a
new one right and I totally understand
that but let's we'll remember what you
guys get paid for and the value that you
bring you don't get paid to do what your
candidates do you're never going to be
as technical as them unless you've come
from the industry right so you get paid
and you need to be an expert in
understanding what the hell is going on
in your market and have a really great
holistic view on your market where are
people move into why they're moving
there what are companies doing great
what how a candidate progressing their
career compared to other candidates you
don't get paid to do what they do so
you're never going to be as technical as
these people so you should not have that
mindset towards your content on I'm not
going to do that so Felicity I'm tech
I'll write blogs about the software or
recruit into that
cool but a lot of people are worried
about writing blogs around technical
topics and then tech people go in
Felicity you're a recruiter shut up and
I totally understand that but for me and
just Ramesh you've got to remember the
value that you bring them what you get
paid to do right so the advice I give to
all of my clients that is really helped
and them overcome this is this
facilitating conversations with your
content right so this is how you can
approach it instead of jumping online
and declaring that your opinion is right
and everyone else is wrong right this is
what cultivates no beds basically and
this is gonna ruffle feathers right so
instead of jumping online and saying my
opinions right you're wrong instead what
I want you to do when I say facilitating
conversations is your opportunities to
go hi everyone this is what I'm hearing
in the market this is what people are
telling me what do you guys think
and you couldn't always pull it back on
your network this is what I'm hearing
from candidates at the moment what do
you guys think and what am i network
thing this is what I'm hearing from
clients at the moment what do you guys
think right and your role and your
opportunity with your content should be
to be the place where can its and
clients can have conversations around
important topics that you know and are
important to people right let me give
you some examples hopefully you can all
see that okay I try to display up that's
one post but I've just cut in half so I
did a post two months ago basically and
I had a number of conversations with
recruitment businesses in San Hisham
really love what you do I know it's
important but I am worried about
investing in my in recruiters personal
brands because what that would
technically mean is that they're
building themselves an asset that they
can take away from our business to
potential yourself on their own or take
it to the next recruitment job right so
that that is that's the business that
I'm in I help recruiters build their
personal brand and I've got people
prospects telling me he she um like I
get it I understand it however I'm
worried about investing in this but
is I'm worried about moral creatures
going elsewhere and using this as an
asset right so one can very easily jump
online and say all recruitment business
owners that have this mindset a stupid
right because that's in more interest to
do that and think that because that's
the business that I'm in right but
instead what I've done and it's
facilitate conversation so what I've
done is said I'm seeing those a great
content at the moment around personal
branding the importance of it why it's
important for recruiters blah blah blah
this is what I'm hearing at the moment
from recruitment business owners they're
telling me they're worried about it
becoming an asset that they can use in
their next potential recruitment venture
or the next recruitment job I don't know
the answer to this it's an interesting
one what do people think of this and all
you put yourself vulnerable as a
business if you're making your best
people more visible right so I said this
is what I'm hearing and then pull it
back on my network and you can do this
with so many topics and it's so
effective let's go on to the next verse
James Johnson who's someone that I work
with that's in the marketing ad space
how are you staying motivated during
this period that's the headline that's
the the salt content topic that he's
identified right and what he said he
said this is this is how long fill in
then he's gone yeah so then he said look
this is this is this is how I'm feeling
this is what we're doing as a company
how are you staying motivated right so
he's gone however people stay motivated
we know that's a topic he's probably
been speaking about of his team or
speaking to that to his candidates and
clients how are you keeping your team
motivated how you stay motivated this is
what we're doing this is how I'm feeling
what do you guys think putting it back
on his network Chris Sycamore again how
jumpy is too jumpy but a job hopping
candidate right and we all we you will
all have an opinion about this again
this is how he approached he I've spoken
someone recently it got me thinking is
jumping this always an issue when you're
looking at hiring for your so he works
in properties facili facility manager
and if so how much is too much again he
said this is what these are the
conversations I'm having this is the
conversation I had of a candidate what
do you guys think turn it back on his
network again right
and there's a good chance if you're
deriving your content ideas from your
conversations that people are gonna have
an opinion on these things right
love Bernoulli's Ferran was in the FMCG
place
how important is salary when deciding to
change role that's the content topic
idea that's what she's talking about
because she's also been speaking to
Candida it's about it about a few
conversations recently sales candidates
I know when I joined my company she's
sharing I think now however the salary
was also super important to maintain the
path to increase here I'm keen to hear
people's thoughts opinions was it salary
what was your motivation right this is
the the sort of content topic idea how
important is that around the sauna
change
role this is what I'm hearing in the
market this is how sort of it's affected
me these are my opinions on it what do
you guys think you can do this with so
many topics and this is how I would
approach doing delivering your content
so the reason why is because when you
approach your content like this guys
it's going to give you the best possible
chance of one driving engagement with
people in your market because there's
going to be a good chance that the
people that have an opinion around these
topics right or if you're having
conversation with candidates and you're
sort of talking about that there's gonna
be other candidates or clients that have
an opinion on that topic and when you're
saying what do other people think on
what are you or force you're encouraging
people to share their two pence in their
opinion right so it's gonna drive
engagement okay and then the other good
thing about this when you're worried
about not coming across the wrong way or
worried about [ __ ] and how this is
a sort of a cute way of getting over
that because basically and what your job
is is you're just becoming the medium of
important topics right so you're not
saying look guys this is right and
you're all wrong you're saying hey guys
this is what I'm hearing this is the
conversations I'm having what do you
guys think so ultimately you becoming
the messenger right you'll just
facilitate in the conversation which
means that people may have an opinion
they made this agree with it but that's
okay because you've you're you may not
even have an opinion when you depend on
the how you do your post you can even
approach it where you technically don't
have an opinion you'll just send this is
what I'm hearing this is what I'm
learning from the market what do you
guys think and when you approach it that
way you're going to minimize the number
of dick as the comment
when people do disagree you can say look
hey Lauren thanks you thanks for thanks
for your thoughts you can just
acknowledge it that's absolutely fine
right and and also it will get you over
that challenge of not coming across the
wrong way to your industry when you're
worried about how they're gonna take it
when you're just saying look guys why
I'm here and don't shoot the messenger
what do people think that is my best
advice with delivering content on
LinkedIn facilitate conversations with
your content I hope that's useful and
just to deliver that I did share this
last time but I'm just going to share it
now I just shared with you or PDF that I
share with my clients that just really
just hammers that home and that that
would be my best advice when you're
delivering content so I'm sorry actually
the final bit the final bit as well
which is why it's important is that when
you're then getting comments and you're
getting people stop and share their two
pence and comment on your content this
then drive your sales conversations this
is this is really important to me it's
all about using your branding efforts
with your proactive outbound efforts
it's about combining the two that is the
powerful mix right and when you sort of
share content and you have candidates
and clients actively commenting on your
post and dropping their two pens you
will then be able to use their
engagement their comments as the reason
why you're reaching out to them right so
this is why I always give this advice is
because if we can get more clients and
candidates sharing our two pens
commenting sharing their thoughts on the
things that you're talking about then
this can really drive your outbound
sales activity when you have X amount of
people come from your post and hey
Lauren this is my thoughts on this this
is why flex will work and the importance
of me blah blah blah or hyaline look I
just wanted to give you a call we
haven't spoken before by notice that you
recently engaged in my content on
LinkedIn look I just want to take this
opportunity to one safe thank you for
engaging my content any feedback on my
content is welcome you may have been
seen that you may have seen on trying to
do more on LinkedIn so if you have any
content ideas that all content
that you'd find really useful please let
me know and by the way whilst I have you
do you know what we do here at X Agency
that's how we drive this you can do that
on LinkedIn or over the phone the
facilitating conversations approach is
gonna fuel and drive your sales approach
this is why I give that advice what is
working today so what I'm gonna segue
into now is what is working today from
what I'm seeing
ok so I've broken it down into these
sort of them these sort of bullet points
from what I'm saying and I know I've got
some really good examples and look just
as I go into this guy's Daniel Torres
Dyer has submitted a question if any of
you have questions make sure you use the
Q&A tab at the top just as I'm going
through this as I'm gonna go through
this and then we're gonna have a really
solid sort of segment on Q&A and
questions and answers I wanna make sure
that I get your questions answered so
let's go through this
so what once in work amongst all the
noise that's going on right now so a lot
of you I love your questions which love
you submitted to me was Hisham how do I
stand out with all this [ __ ] that's
going on right now which I totally
understand long I'm finding that I'm
finding challenging myself so I'm gonna
share what's working for me and what
I've seen work with recruiters so the
first one sharing challenges to make
sure people know it's not just them
experiencing the challenges so what I
mean by that and I've I've shared a post
a few times about this and it's the
first one not going to show an example
one is there will be a lot of people
right now that you're having
conversations with that may feel like
the challenge is there they're that
they're experiencing is just um it's
just them going through that right so if
I'm a parent right now and you're
speaking to me and I'm going look and
Felicity I'm find it really hard I've
got off I've got a five-year-old I've
never had and then running around all
day whilst on front of work from home I
find it really difficult they may think
that that's just them going through that
so with your content and what's working
is making sure that you bring to life
the challenges that people are facing or
that you're facing and saying how other
people coping with this I can't be the
only one experienced in this challenge
how else are other people adapting and
dealing with this right to bring to life
the challenges that you're hearing from
people and make people aware that it's
not just them that's how you want people
to feel there are wild cats really
interesting I didn't know other people
feeling like this right that's the first
piece bringing people together in your
market to share ideas so powerful and so
new recruits to take an action on this
if it's a Webber knife it's a group
video call whatever it may be you're
speaking to candidates or clients or
hiring managers that are likely having
and experiencing the same headaches
right so how useful and how valuable
would it be if you were to bring
candidates or clients together group
video call wherever it may be and how
look so how our approach is hey Lauren
sorry to keep using your name but it's
just cuz I can see it so let's say that
use but you've recognized that a lot of
hiring managers are the sharing with you
the same headaches
hisham look we will interview but we're
really really not sure how to onboard
people remotely right and that's really
general and one that you may have seen a
lot but it's obviously a real headache
right and a real challenge so let's say
that I'm speaking to Lauren the hiring
manager and I'm gonna let Lauren how
open would you be to get an involved of
a group video called what I've noticed
over the last couple of weeks is that
I'm speaking so a lot of people like you
that are experiencing the same
challenges so I thought it'd be a good
idea to bring you guys together free for
other hiring managers that I'm working
with or I'm speaking to you and the
reason for it is I'd like to think that
if we bring you guys together you may be
able to share ideas collaborate or share
solutions share how you've approached it
how open would you be to that you can
bring people together I think it has
never become more normal to jump on a
video call right so I think that's a
great way to approach this bringing
people together in your market
share ideas on how people are adapting
and overcoming the challenges next one
be in the place of positive news this is
going down like an absolute storm and
I've got some great examples on this
being the place where people see the
positive news that's going on in their
market right be the place of positive
news championing people and businesses
who are rising to the occasion another
great one really putting your market and
the people in your market on the
pedestal to say hey these people in our
market are doing an absolute job in
making sure that we're getting through
this together they've done this this and
this or they've hired people remotely or
wherever it may be CH b the b the
recruits that championing people in your
industry right this is so evident with
the NHS right which of course Jesus
Christ
I actually baffles me how I think it's
so easy to take for granted the NHS
right I think just what this is shown is
how valuable and how like the amazing
people in the organization but if you'd
fall in LinkedIn and you see anyone
champion people in their family being a
nurse or just champion anyone that's
part of that organization and is doing
their part it's gonna resonate right be
the pit but be someone that's
championing people that rise into the
occasion who let people know how people
are adapting to the current versity this
is a big one as well again a lot of
people may think that then they don't
know how to come up with solutions or
everyone else's find it really difficult
or whatever but like bring into life how
other people were at that team and
however people are again rising to the
occasion of the adversity again is going
down really well and then the final one
is react reactive content to the news I
don't really do much this myself because
I'm not not on the board that I plan my
stuff but I'm sure we'll have you seen
if you see something that is really
interesting for example and I saw it
sort of fly about like loads over the
last two days obviously the Boris
Johnson recent talk that he did like I
feel really quick and on the ball when
you see like a news article or video or
whatever something related to the news
that you want to share to your network
instant
that's gonna resonate as well and I
think the most recent example is that
Boris Johnson video where I saw quite a
few recruiters share it and it
absolutely flew and obviously got loads
of engagement so that there that's how
I've broken down sort of what's working
today in my opinion what what's been
working with my clients and also from
what I'm saying so I've got a couple
examples and I will send these slides by
the way oh thank you everyone for
sending questions so right I'm gonna let
those I'm gonna let those and build-up
for a second but Felicity thank you to
see Erin a question Laura thank you for
sharing a question Daniel I'll get yours
as well and if you want to ask any
questions and what I just went over
there then make sure you use that Q&A
section I'm gonna go into that in a
second so I'm going to give you some
real-life examples now okay to bring
this to life so when I said about
sharing challenges this is one that I
shared and it was about sort of
switching off
this is something I've personally found
difficult I've worked in every room of
the house that I'm staying at I've
worked in the kitchen living room I'm in
a bedroom right now I've worked in all
have worked in the bathroom I've worked
everywhere right so what I got really
good at because I do find it hard to
switch off especially since having my
own business because it's just you just
thinking about stuff all the time and is
when I left the office I let that's
where I let that that's where I left
working and I'd put my phone on the side
when I got home or whatever but um with
over the last couple of weeks just I've
found it really difficult to switch off
so as you can see there I've said look
this is what I found really tough I find
it hard to switch off this is how I used
to cope I can't be the only one going
through this how are other people
dealing with this might bring to life
the challenge is that you're going
through or that you're hearing to let
people know and make them aware that
it's not just them going through it
through those challenges right trust me
you'll be surprised how many people
think that the challenges they have are
just specific to them but it's very
likely the a lot of people going for it
what they're going through right so that
that's that's the first sort of example
and how I'd approach that
Farren so she posted recently around
business development during covert 19
again bringing this to life something
that again is that she's finding a
challenge you can read that there's
anyone else found that people being
increasingly unpleasant when they call
them on a round cut when it or see it at
the moment in covent nineteen and you
can see what she's put there if you're
someone who's been receiving a lot one
what's a big please tell me how lots to
be a proxy so that you could have think
that I'd be really negative but she just
said look this is why I'm experiencing
remember that we are human beings like
if you are receiving a lot of sales
calls look I'd love to know how how
would you like them to be approached
right same thing bring to life the
challenges that likely other people are
facing right and I'm sure a lot of you
are having the challenge with that
business development during this time
that 100 cent is difficult I've
definitely found that difficult as well
so that's that next one
how could you innovate and offer help
valued runners period like James again
just using Jamie as an example way I
think this is a great thing now I'm not
saying all of you to run donate your
Commission to NHS which what a great
idea by the way but what could you do
what could you innovate what could you
innovate could you I don't know the next
couple of placements donate to a charity
or donate NHS maybe or could you do
something that I don't know think about
things that you can do that it's going
to offer help and real value during this
period right again the like there's just
a great opportunity to be really useful
right now obviously you don't put
yourself at risk of not making money or
whatever but what could you innovate
right now that could be really useful
and just generally be they'll do a do a
good thing right
how can you innovate so this is a post
that I saw from Gabby Trotter and what
good news could you bring to life and
share I guarantee you there's so much
good news that you're hearing about of
people doing that you could bring to
life this is what I'm seeing work so
well and the looks of what Gabby had
been posting she's having post much at
sausage you've got loads of engagement
on this and that's because it because
post them about good news to share today
and bring into life a real story of
someone losing their job and then
getting a new job
and being taken on what a great story to
bring to LA life right how many people
have you helped that found it really
changing recently a bit and then smashed
an interview that you could bring to
life or yeah did get made redundant and
then you've helped me get a new job what
what great things could you bring to
life that is good news that it's gonna
cut through the noise all right and I'm
seeing this work really well so what
good news could you bring to life and
share with your marketer and because
that's going to go down well this is the
same thing how are other people adapting
in your market and what could you share
again in line of what sort of what I've
noticed it's going really well
Adam Jennings you can read that this
week I've had my first connect start
that knew Roger and lock down and he's
brought to life what they're they're
sort of first two days look like
championed the client how they rise into
the occasion and difficult times this is
arguably the biggest challenge with new
staff Connie would love to hit any
success there is of other tech companies
so again so um I did so with Adam and
his team I did do some work with them
and sit them through my program so I'm
not surprised that is facilitating
conversation so he's gone that this is
this is what happened bringing to life a
real success story how are other people
what other success stories that people
are hearing and going through right now
what what could you bring to the market
this that's a success story or how are
other people with that in your market
that you could share right I think again
that's really gonna cut through the
noise right now and then last but not
least what leaders can you bring
together to share real ideas and
challenges so Paul here works in the
insurance market and did his first
webinar last week and I know that he was
quite right about it I spoke to him
about it and haven't done his first one
and he said he really enjoyed then he's
actually hurt so and then this all the
sort of intention of this was bringing
good people together and to share advice
and force on how to survive during Kobe
19 in the insurance market right who
could you bring together what leaders in
your market could you bring together to
share
why these and challenges I'm confident a
lot of you could do that
so before I just move on to that sorry
before I move on to that please please
please any questions you want me to
answer put them in there so the third
and final poll that I'm gonna send to
you guys very quickly because this is
just useful for me to know is I'm
speaking to a lot of people at the
moment around webinars I'm sure you've
seen a lot of people do webinars I
hadn't I didn't I wasn't even thinking
about doing a webinar a couple of weeks
ago and now I've done nearly ten and
I've really enjoyed them I was really
nervous for the first couple of you but
you get the hang of it like anything so
obviously I've learnt quite a bit over
the last couple of weeks so I just
wanted to do a very quick poll on how
useful you'd find it if I was to just
share how you can host the webinar how I
would approach you just because I think
it's a great opportunity in line with
sort of what I'm talking about here and
that can really help you with some
content that's gonna cut through the
noise so let me know on that yeah the
majority of you are saying very useful
okay cool I will action that and I'll
let you all know when I and plan that
but I'll definitely do that because I
think there's a great opportunity guys
to really action that so do these
exercises after the webinar so I've
given you some really good ideas
practical advice on what's working and
like so I've just written some more
ideas there like after this and can we
also have another webinar about the
webinar how to host a webinar yeah I
could do that we'll sort out and but
yeah so just the final slides and this
guys before I got a segue into and Q&A
is look it's all about action you know
you guys have to take action so just
think about one idea don't don't over
complicate it what one idea can I action
this week next week that's in line with
some of the things that I've gone
through today right is that starting to
watch that group with hiring managers is
it hosting the zoom video called for
redundant candidates to give them
valuable advice on series LinkedIn
Profiles open up your diary for 15-20
minutes to just give advice to people
that might be struggling host a virtual
round table hosted webinar on whatever
it may be what ideas can you action this
week tomorrow next week that's in line
with this that's going to help you
become that like help contribute to you
being that lighthouse in your market
with your branding efforts make sure or
you take action people right it's going
to cure now let's do this so let's do
this right so we've got ten or so
minutes and I'm gonna answer as many
questions as I can so let's do this
right Daniel Torres Dyer I think um
Danny email me is what Avenue so as a
small company owner should I be posting
on my company page as well as my
personal profile so ensure Dan the
answer is yes okay and definitely I
think obviously to be smart if you were
to share your own content so you'll put
if you worry about Dan's content and
then I'm confident the stuff that you
talk about and you could also would also
be useful too from your company page
right as especially as you're a small
company is very likely Dan that your
small company brand is built off the Dan
Brown that's the founder brand right so
if that's if that's the case as a small
company on it yes it should be both now
if you're finding it really difficult to
keep up to keep up both then don't be
too hard on yourself then for me if I
was in your shoes because I am in your
shoes it's just a business of me and I
do find if you were to look at my
company pages dan and I find it really
hard to keep up both and what I've found
is some sort of could be really hard on
myself he should want you doing this
they're not that are there and I've just
made the decision that if I make sure
that I just create the content for
myself what I found Dan is that I'll see
if more people know about me they're
gonna know more that they're gonna know
more about my company so in short the
answer is yes - don't be too hard on
yourself which leaves you frustrating
like Fox a
how much poison uncomforted played bar
barbar and thirdly and if you end up
this picking overall for me I'd put more
eggs in downs brand because it's going
to mean if more people know about them
more people will know about your small
business hope that helps right next
question let's do this so if you found
saw sharing a question anyone that wants
to answer a question let me know I will
get it answered Phoebe you're working
with that idea it will work do it you
have to take action this is the key
point and Laura do you have any examples
where people tried using your techniques
or bring conversation the LinkedIn
platform but failed what are the main
mistakes recruits can make without being
aware of their interesting question so
yeah of course Laura there has been
people that have shared content if four
we fought is a great idea and it hasn't
landed and it hasn't or should write
driven engagement so the first part this
Laura and what you have to remember is
100% you're in it for the long game
I don't know that slots such a marketing
thing to say but at the end of the day
Laura you do not decide what makes good
content you have to remember that like
when you're looking at your posting
going oh yeah that's an absolute banger
you don't decide that like the audience
decides that so just really remember
that you have no control of or it's not
down to you if like if you think your
post is great and no one likes it it
obviously wasn't right so that's the
first thing to say don't get too caught
up on what you think makes good content
and what you need to focus on is getting
better at understanding what resonates
and what doesn't and then you can use
what's landed and what's worked well
already to help feel what more you
should talk about and the meaningless
day it's really if I'm honest it's it's
that it's that it's that mindset piece
Laura it's thinking that it's down to
you and to decide or think that what
makes a good content or like you
shouldn't be getting annoyed if no one
likes it whatever it is a consistent
game and you need to just continue of it
but if you do really think about first
what are the biggest headaches
challenges motivations of your clients
and candidates that will give you the
best possible chance of creating content
and for me good content is just content
that is made to feel relevant
the people it's intended for so really
think about that Lauren if you do that
I'm glad to think that you'll have a
very good chance of it resonate em how
that helps next question
[Music]
Alex Wilkie how do I know what time of
day or in the week is best to post is it
worth posting on the weekend too so look
Alexis and no one knows the answer to
that and I'll get that question a lot no
one knows the answer to it from my own
experience what I always try and do is
post in the morning because even in my
days now they're busy and your day as a
recruiter will be busy if I can get a
post up in the morning which typically
is a good time for me then like you can
get that done and then you can worry
about all the other activities and
things that you need to prioritize and
focus on so there is no perfect day to
post or perfect time to post but what
I've always found is the morning window
is a great time to post and always tends
to do well and if I've got a post that I
really want people to see I'm gonna post
it in the morning now with everything
that's gone on at the moment people not
commute in people walking say livering
to start work I'm finding that different
parts of the day Landon than what I'm
used to right even on the weekends so
for me the most important thing Alexis
is that you're creating content that's
relevant if your content is share
whatever time you post whatever day it
is it's not going anywhere
but maybe the morning that's what I
would do so then you can crack on with
everyone else if you want - Alexis
that's that's what I would do so for
Thomas I'm on furlough so you so can't
post Continent seem to be work what sort
of content when you suggest that will
push my personal brand about being seen
as to work-related so if your great
question I've been speaking to people
about this because a lot of my clients
have had to furlough and staff and it is
a bit of a gray area so I think you're
right in terms of yeah it can't be
work-related so Sophie my best advice
and sort of what I've been and speakings
people about and had a group video call
of a crime on Friday about this is
basically Sophia what I would do is
document your own personal journey with
how you're coping and what you're doing
so what I mean by that is it could be
and the how you're stretching your day
to ensure that you don't end up watching
Netflix all day
it could be if you have children the
parent Diaries how are you entertaining
your children whilst being at home on
furlough how are you remaining match fit
to make sure that you're ready to
absolutely smash it when things start
pick up again how other people remain a
match fair how are you
upholding your mental health and
well-being I'm so guys over the last
week I've done Joe Rick's everyone
that's really helps what other people to
do to stay fit so why I would do Sophie
is just document what you're doing as a
person as a human being and again to
bring to life the challenges that you're
facing and that other people are likely
facing or bringing to life what you're
doing that can that's helping you that
likely could help other people just
generally whilst being on furlough or
just being at home or whatever during
this pandemic what could really help and
what are the challenges at your face and
other people face and so that's sort of
how I would approach it and what I've
been telling people Sophie so I hope
that helps right so the next one Ryan
Smith I've been in recruitment for six
weeks four of which from home fair play
I've had a small amount of training but
I'm very aware that I won't have the
experience or network or to hit you're
gonna run with things revert so normal
as I'm new to the industry I don't have
an insight to offer
what else could I offer when trying to
grow my network okay that's an
interesting one what else could I offer
when trying to grow my network I really
do think Ryan right now it's just all
about being a good human being and just
saying just explaining why you're
looking to grow your network and if it's
just and sharing advice if it's just not
on a grow my network because I want to
make sure that I can help people like
this because you're the type of people
that I'm going to be serving when we
bounce back or whatever I mean yeah I
would just focus Ryan on sort of trying
to speak to people get to know them how
they're how they're coping what the
challenges they're facing and just being
a good human is what you could offer
that will go a long way doing the
right thing will go the right way but on
its going to be a challenge Ryan it's
there's no doubt about it it's going to
be a challenge but trust me with the
other live podcast that I've been doing
Ryan we spoke about this a lot if you
really power through this challenge in
time and a lot of people that I've been
speaking to experienced people that had
a recruitment business or work during
the 2008 recession or whatever although
that's different
a lot of people said Ryan if you can
work through what we're going through
right now as a recruiter you will have
every you will have all the capabilities
and the skill sets to be really
successful when we start coming out of
this so long term Ryan you may think it
now this is [ __ ] difficult but long
term everything you're going through now
right now is gonna really help you be
equipped with the best possible skills
you can be to give you the best possible
chance of being successful in the long
run so don't be too hard on yourself the
fact that you're here is great keep a it
be a good human being and and grow your
network can that be a go that will go a
long way
Sophie thanks very helpful so far you're
welcome no worries at all and Alexandra
Alexandra yet okay I'm gonna print up to
on pronounce your surname
sure sure Kia I think that's really bad
sorry and how do you find the line
between professional casual has some
industry differ in the tone of their
post of course I think you'll know your
market better than me
so hundred percent respect the room and
understand that if me posting about
such-and-such isn't probably like me
posting about love Island people
probably aren't gonna be bothered about
that in my market whatever be mindful of
that but at the same time I mean the
stuff that I've seen from you Alex
you'll be in the real human being so I
think that goes a long way don't be too
don't be too hard on yourself as a lots
to professional casual I think the end
the day change those words and use the
word human I think this is the thing
that's massively massively changing now
on LinkedIn LinkedIn becoming Facebook
or whatever you wanna call it I just
think it's that at the end of the day
people connect with your human being you
have thousands of people in your network
and they're connected to Aleksandra I
want to know more about Alexandra this
is the thing that's massively changed a
lot of recruiters and look face lifts
online
so I think don't worry about being
professional or casual just worry about
being a human and if that involves you
posting about live Ireland let's saying
you know that probably people don't want
to [ __ ] know about that or people
don't watch that in your market then
maybe let's not post it but be human
that that's how I would focus on it
instead of professional casual just be
human that's what I would focus on
Alexis Wilkie should i target content
had clients or candidates only you can
answer that and well obviously I can
give me my two pence but what I mean by
that is just aren't yourself this simple
question everyone and the like we don't
need to overcomplicate it if you was to
allocate three hours an hour two hours a
week to your branding efforts how would
you want that to impact your recruitment
desk answer yourself that question how
would you want it to impact the
recruitment desk would you want it to
help you get more client opportunities
would you want it to help you get more
candidate opportunities it might be both
that's fine the great thing is if you're
talking content that's talking to the
candidates is a good chance that's going
to resonate with clients as well as you
all know candidates can become clients
but if you really want to give you the
best possible chance at having a return
on investment sooner rather than later
in the narrow of your recruitment desk
that's going to be more valuable to you
answer yourself that question if it's
clients and business development
opportunities make sure you're sharing
content that's focused on clients do
that first right don't overcomplicate it
Alex Marsh hisham and you mentioned that
the audience decide the quality of your
content but what are the key metrics you
look for firstly understand the ROI on
your updated content is it likes or
comment that you are more interested in
okay cool so how I break it down is
branding metrics so views likes and
necessary yeah views and likes network
growth profile views that's all like
branding more people seeing you more
people seeing your brand and I'll be
measuring those and the next thing then
is engagement how many people how many
human beings have actually stopped and
to comment on my post that's obviously
worth
knowing and for me our comments on
someone's post about it recently for me
like some comments or see a lot of
people say their vanity metrics and all
that that's fine and I get that but the
most important thing that I would be
measuring and what I look at alex is the
relevancy of the people that are
engaging so obviously I know you recruit
in the healthcare space so if you're
sharing content and you're getting not
as many likes were you getting loads of
likes and comments and for me the most
important thing and what I measure is
our is it people in my target audience
that will comment and engaging if so
then that's really valuable and and
that's what I'd be looking at so they're
the branding metrics and then the next
one then is inbound opportunities and
trust me this is how it this is how it
works but you will get people message
you going Alex I've seen your content
I'd love to know how you could help me
that is literally how these messages
will happen and when people just come up
come back to you out of the blue or call
you whatever make sure you're always
asking look Alex but whilst I have you
why did you reach out to me make sure
you're asking those questions but a lot
of the time and you will receive
messages that sound like Alex I've seen
your content and like I'd love to know
if you could help so you'll know when
that happens so it's the branded metrics
and it's the inbound opportunities that
will be referenced in content and then
it's about noticing and picking up on
small wins as well when you're doing
business development when you're calling
people you haven't spoken before oh you
know what Alex I have I do know who you
are senior content that's why I was used
to sort of mentally measured that I'm
building momentum and people asking my
content because obviously the challenge
of thing is that a lot of people may
serve you your content they may not
engage with it and so there's a lot of
people that may be seen your content and
that's obviously a good thing but
they're not actually engaging with it so
sometimes it could be hard to measure
but hopefully that that helps and that's
how I would approach it cool so coming
to the end here Felicity I'm going to
ask your question so over the last I'm
just going to share something with you
all guys this is the first time I'm
actually sharing it and I've been
working my absolute socks off and over
the last couple of months to get this
put together I'm officially
airing and launching it over the next
two weeks but as you guys are more that
are giving me your time you here with me
today which I really appreciate and do
not take for granted I just wanted to
share with you all so I'm not gonna do
like a big sales pitch I've never shared
some sort of offer thing on here before
but I've been working my socks off over
the last month or so to build the sort
of first an online course that's all
about helping recruiters build their
personal brand and I'm really excited to
say that I finally put that together so
I'm going to share this review all now
and look feel free to check it out and
yeah do what you want to do and see what
you think of it and but let me know what
you think and if you have any questions
let me know but there's a discount code
in there that you can all use webinar
and it'll be live until tomorrow to
check it out so I just want to make you
all aware of that because people got to
make money during this time so hopefully
some of you check that out and if you
have any questions let me know
so before I finish félicité I've seen a
lot of Romi post recently I think it is
important to be truthful about the
situation and honest about feelings but
without sounding like a whinging [ __ ]
okay interesting so basically what
you're saying is you want to be either
you want to be human I'm assuming or why
me what do you mean by why me I'm not
sure about that okay let's give this a
go so I've seen a lot of Romi post
recently how about how do you do it
about sounded locker okay cool so you
worried about just being unimpressive
being the wind gym [ __ ] about what's
going on okay I think honestly Felicity
the honest answer is just approach your
content and when you are sharing content
just just being human
okay Felicity said why me as in like oh
poor me life is horrible okay cool yeah
obviously don't to be seen as someone
that is la just moaning because in the
day it could be a lot worse for a lot of
people people are losing family members
to this pandemic and virus and whatever
so
I think that the answer is like you rule
you're all smart people right so just be
empathetic or be human about what's
going on with the situation so I think
using my advice felicity of like
facilitating conversations you might
perceive as talking about something as
being really windy but if you just sort
of say hey this is what I'm finding
really hard and I don't want to come
across the wrong way I'm not whinging
but these are the things that I'm
finding really difficult how are other
people find the net like approaching
like that will help but the bottom line
is Felicity the fact that you're already
thinking about it in terms of not coming
across like that or I'll pull me life is
horrible it's probably going to give is
probably going to mean that and you're
going to be someone that isn't going to
come across like that so the fact you
already are sand that question you're
thinking about it will probably mean
that you're not going to come across
like that so and that that would be my
advice like use the facilitating
conversations advice that will help come
across in the right way and and yeah
just just be a human just don't just be
empathetic and be a real person about it
and right so they all were the questions
that I got so guys that's been another
webinar on personal branding a couple of
minutes before 12:00 but I'm really
happy with that so look I'm more than
happy you should all know that I'm more
than happy to help so if any of you the
best place to get me is definitely on
LinkedIn if any of you want any help or
further advice on the personal brand and
fun drop me a message if you want me to
answer any questions on the online
course let me know about that but what I
will be doing I've got time allocated to
my diary because you've all submitted
questions and you've all submit
questions to be on this webinar so I
will be making my way through all of
those questions that I've got submitted
and I'll be answering them I'll send you
a video or send you an email or message
answering or giving you Monty pence on
that so hopefully that's really helped
guys any feedbacks welcome thank you for
joining me I really appreciate it
hope you all have a great great great
week
and yeah I'll speak to you very soon
I'll let you know when I'm doing the
webinar on the webinar and let take care
stay safe and I'll see you all soon